[Music]
[Applause]
he's Chris Sims pro football talk live
co-host football night America his
podcast is called unbuttoned former NL
Texas quarterback and great contributor
to our program say hello to Chris Sims
here yeah yeah yeah what up how are we
we good thank you thank you
I hope let me see let me see is there a
bruise there there's no bruise yet oh my
gosh oh my gosh it'll be better if it's
broke really the story will be better
right I came around the edge he's going
to milk it for all a nice block by me it
was a good block no it was a low kick
and that's how you blocked it I locked
out I just stuck my arm out my thumb
caught it I was worried that you were
going to take one in the face though
which would have been great content
would have been great exactly okay as
you were yeah uh the number one question
right now this Tuesday at 8:30 local
time with the Super Bowl is what oh um
can the
49ers get back to Peak football play in
a two-e frame right that would be my big
thing we haven't seen the 49ers play uh
the way we all gushed about the ners
right in the middle part of the season
when they went through the the winning
streak there I mean since before the
Ravens game was the last time I looked
at the the 49ers and went oh there they
are hitting at all cylinders Run game
pass game defense awesome it's rare to
be going in the Super Bowl where you've
been outplayed the last two games I mean
you know Green Bay kind of blew it
Detroit in my opinion definitely blew it
right so that is going to be the big
question to me and going to have to be
an adjustment of style of play from San
Francisco as compared to what they've
done because the Chiefs have peaked
right and they're they're still look
like they're going up and they figured
things out and I just don't know where
the 49ers are right right now how much
do you think it's in the back of Kyle
Shanahan's mind what happened when he
was the offensive coordinator with the
Falcons like getting those questions you
know not winning the Super Bowl now
you're back in the Super Bowl play
calling in the Super Bowl does that
change if you're up big or I mean he's a
friend of yours yeah he's my buddy you
know I'm nervous for him because I know
how big this is to his legacy right I
mean he's without question in my opinion
and I don't think it's you know anybody
would be far off he's the best coach in
football with Andy Reid I mean it's four
out of five NFC championship games his
coaching tree the GMS everybody look at
the whole league everybody's just like
did you work for Shanahan we'll hire you
right so but if he loses here it's going
to be oh Kyle shanan can't win the big
game again can't come through and you
know I don't think that's fair he's very
honest and open and direct about
answering these things that you talk
about first off I got a problem with the
Atlanta Falcons 283 thing isn't Dan
Quinn a defensive coach isn't he the one
that's supposed to manage the football
game like last I heard Dan Quinn does
not get blamed for 28 shocking it is
shocking people think Kyle Shanahan was
the head coach of the fal shocking like
I think I've said this to you before if
the roles were reversed and Josh
McDaniels was and the Patriots were the
ones with the lead we wouldn't be going
oh Josh MCD we go what is Bill bich
doing why did they not run the ball why
it's the head coaches to get on the
headset and go hey offensive coordinator
I want to do this right here for this
situation hey run the ball here run the
ball the offensive coordinator is going
to do what he does which was attack that
year right then they have this course of
Super Bowl they lose to the Chiefs and
hey let's be honest that was tough and
the Chiefs are special I mean this is a
special team to be down 20 to 10 and
seven minutes left in a Super Bowl and
come back we don't see that happen very
much and that's CU this quarterback so
uh yeah it is a big day he's got a lot
of pressure on him for sure but he's
still a great coach and uh he doesn't
back down from any of those
conversations with anybody is Kyle
Shanahan in Brock P's ear during the
game well I mean you know until it's
legally cut off yeah but I don't think
it's like it's not um like we've seen in
years past with McVey and Goff where
he's at the line of scrimmage right they
don't huddle so then he can tell him
stuff perie is extremely intelligent
he's you know in a lot of ways found his
Kirk Cousins let's say for lack of a
better way of saying that a guy that's
you know a a football junkie well I can
give him 7,000 rules and checks and
he'll remember them all and he'll be
able to read the defense and almost be
an extension of Shanahan on the football
field but he your comp is Kirk Cousins
it's a it would be something along those
lines right yeah it would be like that
it would be Kirk Cousins is right he's
got a m Jones skill SE is right uh yeah
you know Drew breish but not as good as
Drew Brees or at least I'm not ready to
say that had a little more physical
ability than people want to give him
credit for and I give you credit because
we went from Brock pie Joe Montana yeah
and I'm like no no no how about we come
down the ladder a little bit you're at
least being reasonable and respectable
by saying you know there's a KK cousins
feel to him yeah yes and I and and I
don't say that as an insult I that's
positive to me you could win a Super
Bowl with Kurt Cousins I I believe that
you know again you got to have a team
around you and team's important and I
think we forget about that we're in the
era of and Mahomes and Manning and we
just think quarterback quarterback
quarterback quarterback and you know I I
grew up in Era hey like you know Phil
Sims and the Giants beat the Denver
Broncos Phil was not as good as John
Elway but his team was better so he won
on that day right and he was hot and
played great but I think we lose sight
of that a little bit do we not think Dan
Marino wouldn't have won a Super Bowl or
two if he was on the 49ers in the 80s I
mean that's where I just you can say Dad
won the Super Bowl Dad hey Dad's the man
and he was a baller on the biggest day I
mean he saved his best game for the
biggest day what does he evering bring
that up to you guys the kids he never
like you know maybe has a beer a couple
of beers and it's like uh hey uh let me
tell you about the game against Denver
not at all like he's just not like that
we can get him going on crazy stories
every now and then like tell us a
Lawrence story tell us you know all of
those things explain the Lawrence Taylor
story when he shows up at your house and
your mom answers yeah well this is this
happened on many occasions right so this
is many at least two to three at least
two
right and Lawrence of course was famous
for being out late at night right and
not going to sleep and continuing into
the next day right that's just what
lawence did right that's where I
sometimes hey you got to be who you are
right Lawrence started working out and
like drinking protein shakes I don't
know if he'd have been Lawrence Taylor
right he needed that edge but either way
he would call the house at 4:30 in the
morning and you know I'm down the
hallway and it's old days it's not a
cell phone the whole house is ringing
right
it's and you're like what who the hell
is calling our house right now no call
or ID no call or ID and you know my dad
just oh Diana answer it you know and my
mom answered it and oh y yes hi oh hi LT
oh hi and you know he'd always have
these like crazy comments he'd say to my
dad like what's it you know what's up
with you white people why are you always
sleeping right like say all that stuff
which like we you know we love it was
great it was great uh but yeah he he'd
tell Dad hey I'm going to be there in a
few minutes I need your golf clubs a
pair of golf slacks a golf shirt dad
would be like I don't have any golf
pants that are going to fit over your
big butt and legs you know he'd say that
but yeah then i' you know on on two
occasions like I hear dad get up go
outside and there's Lawrence in the
front in the driveway and he's grabbing
the clubs and feeling them and Swinging
them around and he's got a shirt off and
he's going to put another shirt on he's
going to get changed right in the
driveway and then he's going to tell my
dad to make him a tea time somewhere
local and that's uh we had the pleasure
of dealing with that a few times but it
feels like Old School coaches like Bill
parcel's had to look the other way yeah
right he was Bill bich was the defensive
coordinator they they didn't hold I mean
he was so great they didn't hold him
accountable he it's right it's Bill
bellich who holds everybody accountable
now for you know and he's fam so we're
going to blame bich not the head coach
coach both but this is what's funny
about it is I mean Lawrence at one time
as I I've understood had a sleeping bag
on the floor in the defensive meeting
room right at B Bill balichek's
feet like Lawrence was probably out all
night so they wanted to rest a little
bit so he'd lay on the ground and every
now and then go hey you know hey
Lawrence you got that what we said and
he'd kind of roll over yeah got it and
he would be laying on the ground and it
was a different era definitely not the
same today certainly uh you know maybe a
little less politically correct crazy
iny face letting things go on a lot of
lot of fun those days yeah can't can't
do that stuff now no you can't can't
can't do that stuff they can't even
players now I don't even feel like can
take old school coaching to a degree
right you just you got to find the right
blend and I think that's what's really
cool about these two coaches in this
Super Bowl like if you've ever been to a
Shanahan or an Andy Reid practice it's
extremely intense There Is No Nonsense
you know and then they both have a blend
of no one how to talk to their guys and
be cool with them but yet you know
they're the boss and you know they might
throw a few four-letter words at you
every now and then if they don't like
what you're doing out there and that
that's where they have the Magic Touch
I've been saying this for years and uh
if the commissioner would come on the
show I would say it to if um why can't
we give like you know the Denver Broncos
offensive line against the Packers in
the Super Bowl they were the MVP I I
hear you like can you give it to a group
I know we always want to have the car
you know hey and here's your Chevy truck
yes but to give it to a group I think
would be awesome if you gave it to the
secondary of the Seahawks yeah I think
that would would have been awesome I'm
with you in the fact and I know I've
complained about this with you before of
you know it's it's just are we just in
the era of the quarterbacks going to win
the Heisman the quarterbacks going to
win the MVP every year no matter what
right and yeah there's some Super Bowls
in the past whether you go the Patriots
and Giants Super Bowl 42 right I mean
man the defense holy cow that Day Stray
hand tough won they won the game clutch
and amazing at the end not taking
anything away from him Brady in his
first Super Bowl he had 98 yards
throwing going into the last Drive of
the game he won the MVP with throwing
for 145 yards secondary won that game
right pick six they stopped the greatest
show on Turf so I'm with you in the way
I wish the voters would you know get
away from the eye candy sometimes but
are you allowed to do that they probably
I haven't seen the ballot but it feels
like you know unless somebody starts a
ridein campaign but there are times when
there's a group that wins the Super Bowl
I I don't disagree with you I don't yeah
that Broncos offensive line with Terrell
Davis against the Packers I hear that
would fit that mold too yeah agree did
you make your Super Bowl pick on pro
football talko not yet so before the
year I picked 49ers Chiefs and I picked
the 49ers to win uh well then you have
to stay with them I feel like I do you
know but I'm nervous as I said well okay
how would it look if you're not picking
your friends football team yo I could
tell you how it looks cuz last year last
year I picked Philly to beat them the
NFC championship game right right so I
mean I'm rooting for the 49ers but my
brain said Philly was going to win that
game I mean every one of my and Kyle
Shanahan's friends his family members
like they see it post on social media
and they're all like what the hell right
and I just go I'm just picking the game
it doesn't mean I'm rooting for them so
I think they know that uh but they would
still they'll still bother me if they
saw I pick the but do you still like
deep down yeah you're going to go
against Patrick momes
right now I don't feel like I am no I
think if you made me bet money on the
game right now I would pick the Chiefs
to win I'm shocked right now that the
49ers are two-point favorites I'm
shocked that one team with Patrick
Mahomes is continuing to find its Groove
just beat the Ravens on the road the
bills on the road the Dolphins at home
have dominated and another team hasn't
played good football or its best
football not even nowhere close to it
and they're the favorite that to me is
shocking I don't understand that the
only thing that worries me and think
I've been picking the Chiefs is they
didn't score in the second half against
the reers now that's a great defense
there but they didn't score I know now
they're the type of team that they they
play with their food a little at times
and I think they've also realized like
who they are and that's what that's to
me the biggest thing and I think that's
with the Christmas Day game against them
I had kind of been like hey can we stop
getting in the shotgun trying to throw
40 yard lasers down the field like
you're not that team this year how about
run the ball play defense screens rpos
and you're seeing they're they to me
have kind of hit New England Brady mode
here where it's just like screw all the
stats and how it looks we're just going
to win the game and nobody will really
remember some of the statistics they're
just going to go man Mahomes went into
Baltimore and beat the Ravens right and
that to me is where they've turned you
know turned the leaf or whatever
whatever you want to say there the
phrase of just getting into that mode
and stop trying to be sexy and highlight
film and just go we're going to win the
game and keep adding it up that way and
dominate football and win another
championship and we'll see what happens
on Sunday but you're taking the
ners I I don't know I really don't I'm
really conflicted no I think right now
I'm leaning towards the Chiefs okay you
know I I tooked the Ravens last week to
beat the Chiefs even though I picked the
Chiefs to go to the Super Bowl I did not
think again it doesn't happen in
football this is what's amazing by them
they played B minus football the whole
season all a sudden they got in the
playoffs and they're go we're going to
be A+ and we're going to be the best
team in football and I was like yeah
okay yeah right and here they are and
it's it's incredible I've never seen
anything like the Chiefs it's a very
unique Dynasty they got going great
stuff all allason thank you bu thanks a
lot always appreciate your uh your
analysis your honesty Chris Sims pro
football talk live
co-host and he's going to take the team
that's facing his good friend Kyle
Shanahan that's the kind of friend he is
your former friend Kyle Shanahan uh if
you want to stay around we have some
meat okay there but he's so cool he's
the kind of guy to be like get it I
understand why you're taking my homes he
scary right so that's is that how he
sounds a little bit okay all right we'll
take a break back after this